they're asking for right the beginning
what's the initial flow rate when the
tap is fully on so remember what you've
got is the same scenario we had before
but they're actually controlling what's
happening here right so they don't want
to just I don't know if any of you have
a house that's old enough like mine
where if you suddenly turn the water off
you hear the pipes go through what
happened for him so what they're doing
I'm not the only one well then is there
slowly livre instead of the water slows
down and then it stops okay so
hydraulics is just about floor work so
what they're doing therefore is at time
zero right prior to this at some
negative time right prior to this there
are been well the tap fully on and then
they start to slow it down so right at
the beginning you evaluate DV on dirt
and this is the number you get ok now
I'm just going to put down a vote to say
this right your flow rate is negative
part of what rates of changes about and
every other part of a physical world is
being able to say I can interpret
numbers and tell you what they mean not
just work out what the black numbers are
so i think is vastly superior in this
question to say rather leave it at
negative 2 or even to say the fluid rate
is negative 2 i prefer to say water is
flowing and that negative means
something it means what is flowing out
at such and such a ground he has a much
better way to say it okay I'm later on
we talked about direction in this up or
down or left or right say the words tell
me what on earth is going on poppy same
thing we saw before on the flow rate
where is the tap switched off Tess fully
switched off you know we're doing this
gradually when the volume isn't changing
anymore so that's DV DT so you solve for
that get your value and again I conclude
and that's where I bring my unit soon
okay and now it starts to get more
interesting so Part C have a read it
says given that when the tap has been
turned off there's still five hundred
cubic meters of water left in the tape
fine V as a function of time so this is
a very similar
is that identical scenario to before I'm
going to need to move from dl dt 2 v how
do i do that what's the tool integration
right so the first thing I'm going to
write is V equals and then I'm going to
integrate my flow rate okay so it looks
like this now do you remember I said to
you before are the calculus the
differentiation integration not that
hard as a consequence that one of the
very common areas that people do is
because they're not thinking about that
so much and figuring out all this stuff
people frequently differentiate instead
of integrating for they integrate
instead of differentiating you okay so
always check back and think what on
earth am I doing here and then does that
reflect what I've like so when you
differentiate negative two so when you
integrate the you see how they do when
you integrate negative two what are you
get minus 2t when you integrate or one
on 10 t what happens to the power it
goes up yeah so that power goes up and
then I have to divide by the new pal
which of course is too so I'm getting
that on 20 are you happy with that and
of course because it's indefinite you
should have been happy because now I
have a constant and now it's actually
correct so this point I say well that's
V but I know something about v that will
help me work out this constant namely
when okay what do i do so on Tommy when
T equals 20 that's when the flow rate
stopped you see how all these build on
top of one another I know they're
supposed to be 500 500 meters left right
so in T equals 20 v equals 500 and we're
going to use this substitute in and get
a value out for see so let's just
quickly do that I'm going to get this
how does that look yeah cancel cancel
this is negative 20 over here this is f
hand side so when I add it I'm going to
get that so now i can bring that back
into my original function for volume and
that's my actual function okay we've got
our V and volume as a function of time
where do they want us to take this paddy
says hence find how much water is
released during the time it takes to
turn the tap off how much water is
released so what you're trying to
compare is where you started and where
you end it now in fact I already know
where I mped the question told me right
I'm going to end at 500 liters right so
all I need to is compared that to to the
beginning which is this amount here like
I just worked out if I put into equal 0
it's pretty easy you can see those
disappear so i just want to show you
that though i'm going to say when T
equals 0 or I could just say as easily
say initially volume is equal to 0 plus
0 plus 5 20 right so this is actually my
starting point so i can say therefore
the what's the wedding that they use the
water released what are released and
then all I'm doing here is taking the
difference right I began with 520 the
question itself told me that where 500
cubic meters left when the tap turn it
off so i subtract that which gives me
this and then i'm going to conclude and
bring my unity okay
ok